in the Philippines leading broadcaster
has been ordered to shut down the
telecoms authority says abs-cbn s
license has expired
president Rodrigo Duterte has regularly
criticized the network opposition groups
accuse him of targeting independent
media let's speak to Jamila a Linda GaN
our correspondent in Manila Jamila give
us a background to this case and what
does this decision today mean for the
network will they be able to appeal it
well fully according to the National
Telecommunications Commission the order
of deceased and diseases actually
immediately executory that is something
that also the Department of Justice
Secretary of the Department of Justice
said that it is has to be implemented
right away however abs-cbn continues to
air as we speak it's about 7:00 p.m.
local time the letter was issued and was
received this afternoon but in the
interviews of the commissioners of NTC
with local channels here it remains to
be seen exactly how that will be
implemented whether law enforcement will
have to command to the network networks
grounds and to forcibly force everyone
to stop its airing on free TV now this
is also a complete turnaround to the
issued statement of the National
Telecommunications Commission a few
months ago that it may order and issue a
provisional authority pending the
renewal of the franchise of the network
in Congress now despite denials by
spokespersons of the of the president
that the president has anything to do
with this last year president rodrigo
duterte himself said that he intends to
shut down the network after it failed to
air his campaign as in 2016 now human
rights experts say this comes at a very
unfortunate time when the country just
like the rest of the world is fighting a
pandemic and the biggest media network
with substations across the country with
over 11,000 workers are unable to help
with information dissemination but
despite the legalities fully the
questions of whether it has the right to
air at this point a lot of human rights
experts and media experts are also
saying that this really reeks of
political persecution this is an
impervious curtailment of
press freedom and it's something really
spawned by political and personal
retribution Foley
thank you very much Jamila for that
Jamila a Linda GaN life force in Manila